it's been a
calculated attack on joe right now and
it's it's been boiling and it's boiled
up to february and they decide to pull
the race card in february that stuff
they said has been out forever
everyone's aware of it that stuff has
been out forever you don't think when he
signed with spotify people are aware of
this stuff of course this is a
calculated attack and you can see the
slow boil and then it's
you know black history month what a
better time to spark this than black
history month you know and obviously i
don't
advocate what he said in any means and
you've never heard me say it ever yeah i
don't [ __ ] with it even though the jokes
i don't like comedians do it yeah on
stage i don't [ __ ] with any of it it
doesn't make sense it hurts people's
feelings it's also super polarizing so
it's kind of like when you talk politics
in in the audience half people are going
to love you half people are going to
hate you it doesn't make sense to me you
want everybody to love you so i've never
[ __ ] with it
you know joe's a grown man and that was
before i knew he was doing that stuff
so
you know if you look at what's going on
with joe it's very polarizing and i
think what the right or if you're a joe
rogan
advocator or supporter what you don't do
and you're going to start seeing i
guarantee you start seeing it and to me
this is
[ __ ]
is when you want to go
what about howard stern what about his
background should we go and do it and
it's horrible way worse he's done his
black face he's dropped the n word his
treatment of women like dude if you're
going to cancel anyone that would be a
shoeing that would be easy and sears is
going to have the world of questions to
answer
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] man
you know how easy it would be for joe to
go what about howard sterner you look at
the rock who came out defended rogan and
then backtrack a little bit right and
then they're attacking him now and yeah
oh what about your transphobic grant or
your asian rant you did dude
as you can see left right middle
nobody's perfect but they're not bad
people i don't think listen i grew up on
hearthstone he's a you know he's a
trailblazer he's one of the goats i used
to love him can't stand him now can't
stand him now he sits on his high tower
critiques everybody after he's made you
know more money than god he thinks he's
better than everybody you know if you're
not vaccinated you shouldn't have access
to the hospital just crazy [ __ ] man he's
in his high tower and condemning
everybody and he's changed his ways and
he's no longer the shock jock he's more
of a soy boy leader
but
i appreciate what he did back in the day
and i don't see them get canceled and
the world can't work like that oh this
guy said this but you said this and then
you're doing the same thing that you're
talking [ __ ] about this side you're
gonna do the same thing i don't think we
should work like that of course howard
stern said some terrible [ __ ] back in
the day
times are different now he's changed you
want to talk about somebody who's
changed whether you agree with it better
or worse is it as entertaining no not
even close but he's definitely changed
he's dude he talks about the therapy
he's done he talks about all that stuff
he talks about how he would
certain markets he want to be the head
guy he'd go in a market one of the guys
commit suicide he bullied him so bad he
would go and destroy these markets
because he want to be the top dog at the
time in the culture
that was acceptable
those were different times man
but you talk about a guy who again and i
don't [ __ ] with him in any facet now
especially once we went bad on rogan and
i was a serious subscriber not any more
men i can't stand the guy now we're
gonna be politically opposite i can't
stand him now he's no longer fun
now when he has a celebrity on still the
i don't have i don't hate anybody
i can still separate the two because
he's still to me the best interviewer in
the game when it comes to celebrities
there's nobody better him and mark
martin are the two best buy there's
fantastic rogan's great too but he
really doesn't do the celebrity
interview does he this is conversation
yeah he's conversation you're gonna
learn something from it but he's not
going to have on the big celebrity just
get the views like these guys that's
what they do and that's fine rowan is a
different form of entertainment
i can appreciate all of them but i think
we got to be careful going well this guy
did this too well the rock did this too
i get it well those clips that you watch
with the rock he's a different guy now
he shouldn't be lose jobs or businesses
or opportunities because of these old
weird [ __ ] clips man it was a
different time whether the left right
middle
you got to look at the person now
because i and i think the spotify ceo
said it best goes
silencing joe rogan doesn't help things
it doesn't when you silence these people
it doesn't and i also i view it like
this and i told joe this i talked to him
yesterday i told joe's this
spotify is on joe rogan's platform rogan
is not on spotify don't get it twisted
can go anywhere in the world he needs
nobody and we've never seen an animal
like this not even close
he could go do his own thing which i
hope he does
you know there's a lot of things he
could do
they're not going to cancel but i think
he only has another year and a half left
on his contract so that's not a ton of
time
i think when it's over joe's going to
realize
this stuff only makes him bigger and
right now
right it's a lot of pressure
thank god he doesn't pay attention pay
attention to social media and what
people are saying about him right
but you weather this storm
and the people which is the majority of
america in the world realize joe's not a
bad person i can list off the amount of
people joe has helped in his life and it
would blow your [ __ ] mind and you
guys have no clue you have no clue
i don't [ __ ] with bad people i don't
have any person in my life in my circle
that is a bad person
zero
but if you read headlines about certain
friends that i have you probably think i
do associate that i don't if any of my
friends were actually what the internet
or social media thinks of if they were
actually that person
they dude i would [ __ ] cancel them so
goddamn fast and my life's not even
funny
i [ __ ] with no bad people
only good people hashtag only good
people in my life
out of all my people in my life there is
not a better person on this earth than
joe rogan
no one has done for more for my career
than joe rogan
and obviously that's the thing right oh
the only reason you're anywhere because
of joe sure again you know how many
people joe has helped out and they
didn't have my career or they didn't use
the opportunity and carry carry it and
turn into something great
more more
than other people that came successful
so that doesn't bother me but if i list
off the names black
white asian female
whatever it is he doesn't there can be a
less less racist person on this earth
than joe rogan
i find it hilarious
i find my faith in humanity i find my
faith in the mainstream media is
completely gone after seeing the way
they're treating him it's insane to me
because the media will pick and choose
when you talk about misinformation
are you tell me who hasn't spread
misinformation has joe got all right god
no who tell me one
major network that you listen to that's
gotten every single right during this
pandemic go
i'll listen
tell me one person
that has had the conversations to move
the football down the field more so than
joe rogan
does he get all of it right no man
that's what makes this great is in real
time hope get it wrong and adjust
it's called being a human being and you
want to silence that why do you want to
silence it why did this
this whole
[ __ ] boiling point come to this thing
they've tried everything right they've
tried it misinformation transphobic now
it's racism they've tried it all man
and right now it's it's at its boiling
point and this will pass
and for the rest of america that don't
subscribe to what this cancer culture is
for the rest of the world they don't
subscribe to this toxic toxic silencing
of voices of brilliant minds
do you know what that does to a guy like
joe rogan it makes them bigger
and while cnn views are up or whatever
news network you watch i don't care who
it is they're up using the clickbank of
joe rogan and trying to hate on them
what happens in a month when this is no
longer a story
i'll tell you what happens your ratings
go back to where you were
where they're not [ __ ]
and what happens joe rogan
well humans
are going gonna come up with their own
ideas and decide and look into it
and they're gonna see oh he's a great
dude oh he's a smart guy oh he's
open-minded we said this a while ago now
he says that wow this is refreshing oh
wow it's an open platform where people
can discuss different ideas and have
different opinions but they're still
friends whoa this is crazy what we had
his buddies on they're drinking and
smoking whoa i've never seen anything
like this what do you think happened to
joe rogan
he's 11 million now
i'd be willing to bet you i will [ __ ]
bet my bottom dollar when all the [ __ ]
is done he's at 20 million per episode
the biggest [ __ ] show of all time
so you're helping him you morons
so spotify when you look at it is on joe
rogan's programming
everybody else on that thing everybody
else ain't [ __ ]
nobody has the power that he has
nobody's having the conversations have
because they can't
they don't have the open mind they have
an agenda
they have to have entertaining guests
rogan needs none of that he'll have a
[ __ ] sleep expert on and get more
views than you and i hated that episode
so how do you think this ends
what do you think is going to happen
i will bet my last [ __ ] dollar on it
rogan comes out on top
bet against him man let me know how it
goes for you because again this will be
over in a month and you cowards that
refuse to say anything because you're
worried about your bottom dollar and you
have an agenda
we'll see what happens
you want to side with neil young
you know you know he makes money selling
his catalog correct
he's not anti joe rogan
he's pro money he's pro capitalism
he went to amazon do you know just
recently
he sold his catalog for 150 million
dollars his back catalog
neil young's not making music he's not
streaming new music
anybody anybody under [ __ ] 67 years
old gives a flying [ __ ] about neil young
it's all his old catalog
this was his way of using joe rogan as a
launching launching pad to get to the
money he needed to get and he went to
amazon
but you're going to sit on your higher
moral ground and consider that a better
opportunity because of the joe rogan
spread misinformation you know they have
r kelly on spotify correct are you cool
with what he did you didn't say anything
about that
you're cool they sell bill cosby content
on it are you cool with that
you say anything about that so your
moral high ground doesn't mean [ __ ] this
was a money play that's all this is as a
money play
look into it i'll use a famous eddie
bravo quote look into it and again i
will bet you any amount of money
who do you think comes out on top
these bottom feeders who want to
criticize and cancel joe rogan who's one
of the smartest minds one of the kindest
souls we've ever had on this [ __ ]
planet doesn't need to be doesn't need
anybody
just look at his body of work what he's
done with comics the comics he gives it
super opportunities to open and forming
from arenas males females
i won't say her name he had a female who
was just starting comedy and he had her
hosting rogan and friends
sold out shows four nights a week then
brought her in front of [ __ ] arenas
not because it's the cool thing to do
and he wanted to mix it up and have a
female voice because she's [ __ ] funny
and that's the way business and comedy
should work
the funniest person i don't give a [ __ ]
if you're trans
chinese gay
fat skinny in shape tattooed cauliflower
ears i don't give a [ __ ] if you're funny
you should get up there
over the people that aren't funny even
though they might be a different race
they might be a different
sexual orientation
that's not the way comedy works that's
the way sports works
that's the way hollywood works and how's
that going for you
how's it going for you guys
we have the power now
and when the talent realizes we have the
power you guys are [ __ ] straight up
we don't need anybody
we need nobody
you guys need us
but you're gonna have your puppets that
play the game and have to play the game
they'll be around for a little bit
but we're moving the marker and it
starts with joe rogan
and we're moving the marker with the guy
who's smarter more talented more kind
not racist
and richer than you
i'll bank on that guy
while the rest of you sit behind your
keyboard
and your board rooms and criticize
because you know what we're not going to
do is go we'll look at what howard stern
said look what the rocks it because
that's not moving the needle all that
does is cancel those guys we need those
guys i think rock's a fantastic person i
think the message and the hope that he
gives people is fantastic
i root for that meat head i'm a meat
head
i think joe rogan has changed the
narrative on meat heads but you guys
might say oh he's just this meat head is
he yeah he works out man
yeah he has a lot of muscle i hate to
tell you smarter than you he's more
open-minded than you
he's changing the world for the better
silence him makes this worse
if you have kids and i have two i have a
five and two-year-old
do you want to come up in a world where
the voices that are different than your
mainstream media get silenced
because they don't have an agenda and
can't sell your [ __ ]
vaccines is that what you want
or do would you like an open playing
field where your kids can learn and
listen from this perspective this
perspective and they come up with their
own decision doesn't that sound great
doesn't that sound great whether you
agree with what rogan has said
in the past whatever it is wouldn't you
like a world where your children grow up
and they're not sheep
and can listen to different perspectives
and then come up with their own identity
instead of pushing a false narrative
wouldn't that be great
well you have a guy who's doing that and
you're trying to silence him and the
world will not be better you silence him
and i hate to tell you
but you can't silence him this is a
fight you guys will not win in any facet
you're making him bigger
he's on every [ __ ] major headline in
the world right now and what's going to
happen is even people that don't [ __ ]
with them
let's say it's 100 million people 100
million people don't [ __ ] with them and
they see the headlines and they tune in
this guy's pretty smart
this guy's pretty open-minded wow
he's actually really kind oh he's a dad
yeah he's a dad father of three oh wow
he's self-made hey self-made man holy
[ __ ] you signed the biggest deal in
podcast history yeah man yup didn't even
plan on it just started doing it
just started doing it from his [ __ ]
bedroom and it blew up to the biggest
most powerful show in the world why is
that is it because
he's this hateful character hate never
wins
never wins like you list off a bunch of
comics and podcasters where all they do
is hate on other individuals their
numbers aren't great they don't do well
on the road
you have a small demo that [ __ ] with
that but in general the big boys the
guys who make in this business are
kind-hearted
they're open-minded and they're good
people for the majority of them they're
great [ __ ] dads
and how you base a person i don't give a
[ __ ] what business they're in what
profession they're in you judge them
based off the way they treat their kids
joe rogan has taught me so much in life
more than anybody else in my life
more so than anybody i've ever had in my
life and you know what he does he leads
by example
he's the best dad i know
i'm a [ __ ] beast of a dad i pride
myself on that
i learned that from joe rogan
open-minded apologizing
you gotta be careful apologizing though
because that's what they want right you
go too much you lose this fan base
apologize for your mistakes but don't
apologize for being who you are
but again
this meathead
can apologize for previous mistakes
because he's open-minded and he's smart
enough to know he's made a mistake when
other people double down and never back
down that's not joe rogan
when i tell you guys
you're not gonna win this fight you're
[ __ ] with a different animal
that has a bunch of other [ __ ] lions
running with him
and we don't need hollywood we don't
need any of you
and our leader is the smartest
kindest
open-minded non-racist non-transphobic
guy you've ever met in your life and he
has all the money
so your [ __ ] move man what else you
got jen
you